what would you say is the biggest
mistake that independent filmmakers make
when it comes to marketing and
distributing their films not having a
plan not again we go back to not knowing
who who is gonna like this work for
documentaries it's easier because
usually there's a cause or an interest
that's very much at the heart of the
piece for narrative films more difficult
and I tell people to look at what is the
emotional core of the work you know is
it meant to be edgy is it meant to be
anti-establishment is it meant to just
be romantic and illogical and impulsive
you know those kind of emotional
resonance because you can figure out an
audience type based on an emotional
response and you can start there again
like I said it's best to start with
yourself the reason why that you wanted
to tell the story but it gets incredibly
vague about where to go in the direction
if you haven't done that work to figure
out who's going to watch it and it's
much harder for the filmmaker and for
sure a distributor when you have a
low-budget film with nobody recognizable
in it and a very broad story that could
be Universal because you don't have a
lot of money to market the film and you
know how many stars to hang the
marketing on you know usually when a big
studio makes a romantic comedy or a
quirky comedy or a coming-of-age story
they use known actors in it because
that's the easiest thing to hang your
marketing on people know those people
and they go to see their work if you're
an unknown director or if you're you
know if you have a name as a director
you might attract people to seeing the
kind of movie that you make Edward Burns
would be a good example of that because
he doesn't always have stars in his
films are known people in his films but
he's a known for
it's the most challenging when it's a
hard hard category to define film with
nobody in it and no way to really reach
out and advertise your way out of this
you know to to just blanket the place
and hope that you get some viewers one
that's kind of wasteful but at least you
feel like you're doing something and to
that that you probably don't have a lot
of money to do that with so you aren't
gonna be able to depend on it so a lot
of times when I get approached in script
stage if I can if I can stop somebody
and have them take a step back and say
you know maybe this story based on the
budget you have now is not the one to
tell right now so put this one on the
side for for when you do have more money
when you have had some modicum of
success with something else that you can
attract people to that story and it's
okay that you have this idea but it
can't be realized yet and it's on the
back burner but no these are the
elements I'm going to need in order for
this story to be successful to an
audience now if that's not your goal you
know that you just this is a passion
project you really feel like you have to
tell this story and you don't really
care how many people are gonna watch it
a big group of people are gonna watch it
or that you're gonna make any money sure
you know if you're realistic with
yourself at the beginning and you know
that that's not gonna have likely to be
happening ya start go now you know but
if if you're just starting out and you
have a very limited budget to spend and
you have some goals like I really want
to get it in front of a bunch of
eyeballs or I really want it to get
industry attention make something that's
identifiable the audience is
identifiable and fairly easy for you to
reach with your labor efforts and it's
not going to be dependent on spelling
spending a lot of money in ads or hiring
a big publicist or that it must get into
one of the five big festivals in the
world or it's not going to go anywhere
because that's the realistic you know
those are the realistic things that it
has to have so many elements before it
really can get in to
to realizing those goals so yeah I would
say that the biggest problem is that
they don't think enough about who is
going to to see this
you